non mesdames et messieurs mes chers amis
je voudrais commencer par remercier tous
ceux qui ont contribué à la préparation
de cette matinée de travail
bien sûr et rigueur notre secrétaire
général en charge du projet qui fait un
formidable travail
isabelle le callennec notre vice
présidente angélique delahaye annie
genevard marc philippe daubresse edouard
course hier jean pierre vigier jean
louis costes
arnaud viala pierre morel à l'huissier
et bien sûr pierre charon tous les
intervenants du président montredon et
vous tous mes chers amis le monde
agricole traverse une crise absolument
majeur et chaque français qu'ils
habitent dans la ruralité qu'ils soient
proches ou non de l'agriculture ou des
enjeux de l'agriculture doit comprendre
que nous sommes tous concernés par le
drame car c'est un drame que vivent tout
à la fois l'agriculture française et la
ruralité
nous avons une obligation morale à
l'égard de nos agriculteurs
ce qui est en cause ce n'est ni plus ni
moins que l'abandon d'une identité
française et de la première filière
industrielle française la
désertification peut s'abattre sur un
territoire avec une rapidité stupéfiante
mais une fois que la diversification
certification a eu lieu rien ni personne
ne peut inverser le système
aujourd'hui l'agriculture est devenue
une variable d'ajustement de la
politique écologique du gouvernement
il faut dire les choses comme elles sont
le gouvernement le parle d'agriculture
que quand il ya une crise ils sont
servis et l'agriculture n'est que la
variable d'ajustement d'accord
politiciens avec une écologie
politicienne au service des intérêts
politiciens d'un président de la
république politiciens et gt1 c'est
clair les agriculteurs nous lance
aujourd'hui un appel au secours
pourquoi
d'abord il ya la chute des prix
agricoles qui fragilise dans des
proportions invraisemblables l'activité
des agriculteurs français
je pense aux éleveurs bovins pour ça je
pense à la production laitière
mais je pourrais parler aussi des fruits
et légumes et de tant d'autres sujets et
comme si cela ne suffisait pas la chute
des cours
il y à l'invraisemblable l'embargo russe
sur l'agriculture européenne
mais comment nos dirigeants ont-ils pu
s'enfermer dans un piège aux
conséquences dramatiques pour notre
agriculture
comment c'est près d'un milliard d'euros
c'est les agriculteurs français qui
payent les errements de la politique
étrangère de la france
comme si la priorité d'aujourd'hui
devait être de créer les conditions
d'une nouvelle guerre froide alors que
depuis 1989 lit de mur de berlin s'est
effondré nous ne pouvons pas accepter
cette guerre froide qui ne dit pas son
nom avec la russie j'apprends que
monsieur le foll s'est exprimé pour la
levée des sanctions contre la russie il
paraît même que monsieur hollande est de
cet avis mais qu'est ce qu'ils attendent
donc pour agir
quel est le blocage au final voilà le
bilan de françois hollande en 2015 la
france n'est plus la troisième puissance
agricole exportatrices en quatre ans
nous sommes passés du troisième rang au
cinquième alors livré que le président
nous avait promis d' inverser les
courbes de ce point de vue c'est un
triomphe alors je veux affirmer à ce
point mon propos que l'agriculture est
un sujet régalien au sens où
l'agriculture doit être une priorité de
l'état car l'agriculture est la première
industrie française en nombre d'emplois
je veux parler de l'industrie agro
alimentaire
notre ambition doit être de remonter sur
le podium à la troisième place des
exportateurs agroalimentaire mondial
avant 2020 et de re devenir la première
puissance agricole européenne
notre objectif est très simple nous
voulons la première agriculture d'europe
et nous voulons la troisième agriculture
exportatrice du monde
pour cela nous devons analyser les
souffrances du monde agricole chance
sociales et administratives excède nomme
fiscalité inadaptée trop lourd par
rapport à nos concurrents européens
manque d'investissement quand on se
prononce pour défendre l'agriculture
française on est immédiatement catalogué
comme contre l'écologie
je suis très heureux de la présence de
maud fontenoy
on a enfin quelqu'un qui parle avec
compétence de l'écologie etc a compris
que l'écologie ne vais pas être
l'adversaire de l'agriculture comme
l'agriculture n'est pas l'adversaire de
la protection de l'environnement les
agriculteurs sont les premiers
défenseurs de l'environnement d'abord
parce que c'est leur outil de travail
le sol les nappes phréatiques sont les
ressources dont ils ont besoin pour
leurs élevages pour leur culture est par
ailleurs les premiers à être exposés aux
conséquences d'une agriculture intensive
sur les agriculteurs donc sauf à croire
qu'ils sont irresponsables
ce que je ne crois pas c'est leur faire
un bien mauvais procès nous nous voulons
faire confiance aux agriculteurs quant
au respect de l'environnement
c'est la raison pour laquelle et c'est
notre première proposition
je souhaite que nous assumions nous les
républicains le passage d'un principe de
précaution un principe de responsabilité
au nom de la précaution on s'abstient de
faire au nom de la responsabilité ont
fait et en assume les conséquences
il faut tourner le dos à la culture de
la déresponsabilisation et au refus du
bon sens quant à l'expression bizarre
d'agro écologie c'est le faux nez d'une
véritable obsession pour la destruction
de notre puissance agricole qui serait
remplacé par la possibilité donnée aux
bobos d'aller faire leurs courses à la
ferme dans le cadre des circuits courts
nous voyons combien on pourrait toucher
le béret et on aurait même le droit pour
chaque produit acheté tout faire une
photo ce n'est pas les agriculteurs pour
moi c'est pas une espèce en voie de
disparition et ce ne sont pas des
cantonniers je précise avoir le plus
grand respect pour les cantonniers
les agriculteurs sont des entrepreneurs
qui ont un savoir faire qui sont des
producteurs
c'est une industrie ils ont comme le
disent les anglo saxons un goodwin
savoir faire ils doivent être payés avec
des prix et pas avec des subventions
les agriculteurs n'ont pas vocation à
devenir fonctionnaire ils sont deux
producteurs des entrepreneurs à qui on
doit assurer des prix qui soit plus
élevé que leur prix de revient
je voudrais prendre en notre nom à tous
plusieurs engagements
le premier après la suppression du
principe de précaution remplacé par un
principe de responsabilité sera un
moratoire général sur la sueur
transposition des règles européennes
nous refuserons toute norme européenne
en france qui seraient supérieurs à la
moyenne des normes européennes
pas de sur 30 positions car on se trouve
dans la situation où après que la
commission se soit passionné pour la
courbe des concombres on est heureux
qu'il est fonctionnaire européen qui
n'étaient pas débordés puisqu'ils ont pu
s'occuper de la courbe des concombres
nous mêmes avec notre administration
parfois nous en rajoutons donc premier
point je veux que cet engagement soit
entendu plus de sueur transposition de
normes européennes en france troisième
engagement de précaution responsabilité
refus la sueur transposition
je souhaite que nous nous engagions dans
une démarche de déconstruction de normes
nationales obsolètes et inefficaces et
je prends l'engagement qu'aucune nord
nouvelle ne sera édicté sans que les
agriculteurs n'aient été consultés
préalablement et je veux que dans les
préfectures le préfet redevienne un
interlocuteur le préfet aujourd'hui n'a
plus de pouvoir manger et dévoré qu'il
est par l'ensemble de ses directeurs qui
fait qu'il n'ya plus aucune marge de
manoeuvre pour discuter avec qui que
cela soit donc les préfets auront la
charge de la déconstruction des normes
nationales
j'ajoute que dans notre esprit nous
voulons une société française fondée sur
la confiance sur la responsabilité et
sur la liberté
je veux dire un mot de l'innovation dans
l'agriculture il faut arrêter avec cette
idée moyenâgeuse que le problème vient
du progrès de l'innovation et de la
recherche
c'est la solution qui est dans
l'innovation le progrès et la recherche
nous sommes la première génération
c'est sous la pression de cette pensée
socialiste a peur du progrès a peur de
l'autonomie a peur de la liberté a peur
de l'innovation
c'est la réponse aux défis de l'humanité
c'est exactement le contraire que ce
qu'on nous propose
même impression que le retour à la
bougie cette baisse de 9,7 à l'hgy du
c'était mieux avant condé a une vision
totalement invraisemblable du monde où
la france serait un espace comme une
réserve on continuerait avec les chevaux
pour tirer la charrue et où l'idéal
serait absolument de revenir à des
process on sait ce trop refusant la
modernité partout dans le monde on
innove
il ya 500 millions d'européens il ya 400
millions d'américains nous sommes moins
d'un milliard par rapport à 7 milliards
d'habitants sur la planète
il ya quatre milliards d'habitants en
asie il y aura bientôt deux milliards et
demi en afrique et nous nous devrions
donc être la région du monde
la sole on a peur du progrès de la
recherche de l'autonomie des chercheurs
et de toute l'innovation dont
l'agriculture a besoin
j'en suis encore à me demander ce qui a
pu passer par la tête du gouvernement
lorsqu'il a supprimé d'un trait de plume
la tva compétitivité que nous avions
fait voter le baisser massivement les
charges dans les exploitations agricoles
fallait-il que la détestation à notre
endroit soit elle
j'avais pris l'impopularité de
l'augmentation il n'avait qu'à faire ce
qu'il sait le mieux faire dépenser
l'argent des autres et bien même ça
c'était pas possible
il a fallu revenir sur la tva
compétitivité ce qui naturellement a
privé l'agriculture française d'un
rééquilibrage par rapport à nos qu'on a
nos concurrents européens
je voudrais dire des chiffres qui sont
accablants il ya une main d'oeuvre moins
chère de 50% dans les fruits et légumes
et 20 % dans les autres filières comme
la viande en allemagne donc on n'a pas
fait l'europe pour avoir du dumping
fiscal et du dumping social
comment voulez vous que nos producteurs
de fruits et légumes et nos éleveurs
puissent s'en sortir avec un
différentiel de compétitivité sur les
charges de 50% sur la filière des fruits
et légumes et de 20% sur la filière de
l'élevage
sans compter ce qui se passe dans les
abattoirs de nos partenaires allemands
ou des personnes venant d'autres pays
parfois le trachome une autre extra
communautaires sont payés bien en
dessous des salaires des propres
nationaux allemands ce qui est
naturellement interdite en france
je n'accepte pas la concurrence déloyale
et je veux dire très clairement que nous
demanderons de revoir profondément la
règle dite du détachement
nous n'avons pas à accepter en france
des travailleurs qui sont payés comme
les français d'accord mais qui ne payent
pas les mêmes charges que celle qu'on
paye parce que si c'est le cas pour les
salaires ça doit être également le cas
pour les charges
l'europe n'est pas fait pour être le
cheval de troie d'une concurrence
déloyale et ça va nous amener à réduire
les charges sociales des emplois
permanents dans l'agriculture pour
rétablir les conditions de la
compétitivité
j'aurai l'occasion demain de dire
comment nous serons mais pour nous c'est
clair il n'y a pas d'autre solution pour
relancer l'emploi en france qu'un
mouvement de baisse massive de charges
pesant sur les emplois dans
l'agriculture dans l'industrie et un
certain nombre d'autres secteurs c'est
pas la peine de vouloir augmenter les
subventions c'est les charges restent ce
qu'elles sont notre agriculture finira
par disparaître
nous préférons connaître aux
agriculteurs le statut au combien plus
valorisants d'entrepreneurs que celui
d'assister statut que les agriculteurs
n'ont jamais demandé
je refais l'histoire parce qu'il faut
dire la vérité maintenant lorsqu'on a
baissé les bras
trentaine d'années sur la question des
prix mondiaux
on a dit aux agriculteurs ce qui fut un
mensonge
ne vous inquiétez pas on compensera la
baisse des prix par l'augmentation des
subventions avec les subventions chauffe
de les formulaires avec les formulaires
sont venus les contrôleurs et quand tu
appuies d'argent vous avez gardé les
formulaires et les contrôleurs et vous
avez perdu les subventions voilà la
réalité du piège dans laquelle on a
enfermé l'agriculture française sans
parti
lle et l'agriculture européenne général
et je veux revendiqué avoir toujours
défendu l'idée d'une régulation des prix
je n'accepte pas la spéculation sur les
prix des matières premières en général
et sur les matières premières agricoles
en particulier les camps les céréales
par exemple la quantité physique de
céréales produites chaque année est
vendu 10 fois donc il ya bien un moment
donné ou via un petit peu de spéculation
entre ce que paye le consommateur est ce
que touche le producteur ne parlons même
pas du pétrole ou entre le tanker qui
transporte sa cargaison de pétrole entre
le moment où il part et le moment où ils
arrivent il a changé cinq fois de
propriétaire donc la question de la
régulation du prix des matières
premières et de la remise en état de ce
top de régulation est clairement posée
notamment pour l'agriculture
si on veut bien considérer que le
problème de l'agriculture
c'est d'abord les prix je voudrais aussi
de cinquième mesure qui est très
importante puisqu'elle est demandée
depuis très longtemps et je crois qu'il
faut que nous y passions
nous allons nous engager à autoriser le
lissage fiscal des pertes comme des
bénéfices des exploitations agricoles
sur une durée de cinq années
pourquoi parce que parfois les prix sont
hauts
la recette est bonne l'année suivante
les prix sont bas la recette est
mauvaise mais il faut payer les impôts
dans l'année où les aléas ont fait que
c'était mieux
j'avais ya quelques années inventée pour
les auteurs c'était bien avant la france
pour la vie je peux pas être accusé de
plaidoyer pro domo un lissage
c'est à dire que j'estimais que l'action
de création d'un film d'un livre cher
eric woerth ou da
2 un disque c'est est soumis à l'aléa et
donc on permettait d'étaler le paiement
des impôts sur les cinq années suivant
la récolte j'avais dire moment on a
touché les droits d'auteur eh bien nous
proposerons aux entreprises agricoles ce
lissage sur cinq années
ce qui est un changement considérable ce
n'est pas une niche pour les
agriculteurs puisque ça existe pour les
sauteurs et ça permettra de tenir compte
de quoi de tenir compte de l'aléa qu'est
celui de la production agricole en leur
permettant d'étaler leur revenu sur
plusieurs années je voudrais également
dire combien je crois à la
contractualisation interprofessionnelle
je veux prendre le contre-pied exacte de
la politique conduite depuis trois ans
le détricotage des mesures
d'organisation des filières
agroalimentaires qui a été orchestrée
par le gouvernement est à l'opposé de ce
l'on a besoin notre agriculture pour
s'organiser et pour favoriser une plus
équitable répartition des marges
l'abandon des primes pour
l'engraissement des accords de filières
qu'on avait mis en place en 2011 a été
une erreur
et chacun peut le comprendre compte tenu
de la force la distribution compte tenu
du nombre de producteurs agricoles si on
ne rentre pas dans la contractualisation
et la réorganisation professionnels
interprofessionnelle comment voulez vous
qu'on ait de la transparence sur les
prix et comment voulez vous que le le le
partage de la valeur ajoutée se fasse
avec équité
si chaque agriculteur seul dans son coin
et l'essai face à la grande distribution
comment voulez vous qu'ils s'en sortent
c'est pas la peine de le regretter mais
souvent vous m'avez entendu le dire au
lendemain de la guerre il aurait été
mieux valu que le monde agricole
investissent dans une dans la
distribution que dans la banque
on serait pas aujourd'hui
dans la situation où il ya un tel
décalage entre le producteur et le
distributeur
parce que la banque y en a beaucoup on
avait eu crédit agricole sur une autre
forme
mais la distribution en éloignant le
producteur que sont les agriculteurs du
consommateur en gommant la part de la
distribution
d'abord c'est toujours mauvais quand le
producteur n'est pas en lien avec le
consommateur parce qu'il ne le connaît
plus et deuxièmement la la valeur
ajoutée se perd en quantité
d'intermédiaire ce qui fait qu'on a
aujourd'hui un monde agricole qui se
sent abandonnée
il faut que l'état vienne à son secours
pour rééquilibrer les conditions du
partage de la valeur ajoutée enfin se
posera la question de la pac de la
prochaine politique agricole commune là
que les choses soient claires je n'ai
jamais vu cela et j'ai une certaine
expérience des négociations européennes
il n'y a pas un seul français au cabinet
du commissaire irlandais à l'agriculture
mes chers amis ça ne s'est jamais
produit on me dira c'est un détail vous
auriez raison mais c'est un détail
tellement révélateur
ça veut donc dire que le ministre de
l'agriculture n'a pas été fichu de
prendre son téléphone pour dire au
commissaire européen à l'agriculture
mais enfin la france est une grande
puissance agricole vous n'avez pas un
seul français à votre cabinet est-ce
qu'il a pas de téléphone
est-ce que je dois de lui donner le
numéro de téléphone du commissaire
européen à l'agriculture
comment voulez-vous que sur un détail
comme cela où il a été parfaitement
inefficace est absent si on est absent
là dessus vous vous rendez compte quand
il s'agit de négocier l'avenir de la pac
alors l'avenir de la pac et les
négociations internationales
pour moi c'est clair la pac doit être
sanctuarisée et c'est pas simplement un
enjeu économique
c'est un enjeu politique et je veux
qu'on m'entende un continent
autosuffisant en production
alimentaire est un continent
indépendants un continent qui est obligé
d'importer la nourriture qu'il donne à
ses habitants est un continent
dépendants c'est un objectif stratégique
majeur l'indépendance alimentaire de
l'europe
j'ajoute que ça m'étonne toujours qu'on
nous fasse des leçons sur le principe de
précaution et qu'on maltraite tellement
la production agricole européenne ce qui
nous met dans les mains des autres ce
qui fait qu'on continue à produire des
normes qui s'appliquent à des produits
français qui ne se fabriquera plus en
france ou en europe mais a importé
quantité de produits ou là on leur pose
pas de questions sur les ogm et sur la
façon dont les pesticides ont été
utilisés donc on impose des normes à nos
producteurs et on importe des produits
venant de pays où la traçabilité
ça n'existe même pas donc c'est un
objectif stratégique
je demande la sanctuarisation de la
politique agricole commune
je demande d'ailleurs autre chose je
trouve que l'europe s'occupe de beaucoup
trop de choses qui va falloir revenir à
une europe qui comprenne qu'elle a une
petite dizaine de priorité je souhaite
que l'europe abandonne une bonne part
des compétences communautaires actuelles
pour rassembler les compétences
prioritaires autour d'une petite dizaine
de politique de politiques européennes
majeures comme la politique agricole
comme la politique de recherche comme la
politique de concurrence comme la
politique industrielle on pourrait en
chercher d'autres
et qu'elle se concentre sur des
objectifs nassif
je ne vois pas pourquoi on doit mettre à
genoux la politique agricole européenne
pour la sacrifier à la politique
agricole américaine
les américains eux savent défendre leurs
fermiers nous devons savoir pétanque les
agriculteurs européens
un mot sur cette affaire de paquets
neutres ce que des bêtises j'en ai
entendu dans ma vie des démagogies j'en
ai vu mais on la sphère du paquet neutre
elle est tout à fait liées à la journée
qui nous occupe mes chers amis parce que
si nous acceptions le paquet de
cigarettes neutre dans six mois on vous
proposera la bouteille de vin neutre et
s'en sera fini de nos appellations il
s'en sera fini de nos terroirs
il s'en sera fini de la défense dans
notre savoir faire
pourquoi je vous dis ça mais il suffit
de réfléchir si vous l'acceptez le
paquet neutre pour les cigarettes mais
vous aurez demain des intégristes qui
vous demanderai la bouteille neutre puis
on aura aussi le fromage neutre on a
déjà eu le président normal
c'est une bataille beaucoup plus
importante qu'on imagine c'est la
bataille de nos appellations
c'est la bataille de notre savoir faire
c'est la bataille de notre identité
c'est la bataille de notre histoire
c'est la bataille de nos terroirs et si
nous cédons là nous céderons surtout je
ne dirai qu'un beau pour le rappeler
s'agissant de la régulation des marchés
de matières agricoles
écoutez c'est bien simple depuis 2012 je
voudrais savoir de quoi s'est occupé le
g20 ça m'intéresserait et je poserai une
deuxième question je voudrais savoir
quelle est l'initiative depuis 2012 que
le g20 prise ça m'intéresserait aussi
beaucoup et je pense que le g20 devrait
se saisir à l'écouté de cette situation
très préoccupante des cours des matières
premières
nous avons un baril qui est passé en
dessous des 30 dollars
en vérité toutes les matières premières
sont indexés sur le cours du baril ce
qui parlait un peu rapidement de la
bonne nouvelle d'une afrique qui
repartaient économiquement n'ont pas vu
les conséquences de la chute dramatique
notamment des prix des matières
premières minerais qui crée une
déstabilisation complète avec
aujourd'hui des investissements des
investisseurs agressif qui parient à la
baisse voilà la réalité des choses qui
parle du prix des matières premières
parce que ne vous réjouissez pas parce
que si c'est aujourd'hui à 28 dollar
ça peut être demain à 130 parce que les
mêmes causes produiront les mêmes effets
et à ce moment là les mêmes spéculateurs
joueront à la hausse ce qui joue
aujourd'hui à la baisse et ça se fera au
détriment des pays pauvres au détriment
des producteurs et le monde et
l'économie mondiale ne peut pas
supporter ces mouvements de yo-yo je
crois au marché je crois à l'offre et à
la demande
je crois à la concurrence mais je crois
à la concurrence
loyal et je crois que le marché s'est
pas toujours la règle du plus fort c'est
la règle avec un arbitre avec des
possibilités de s'exprimer dans des
conditions qui sont équitables pour tout
le monde
il ya déjà assez d'aller 1 avec le
climat pour ne pas rajouter avec la
spéculation
j'ajoute que il est urgent de remettre
de l'ordre dans les organisations
internationales agricole il y en a
beaucoup trop
elles sont inaudibles et absolument
invisible
enfin je souhaite parce que nous avons
voulu avec eric isabelle que vous ayez
peu de mesures mais des mesures fortes
ne me méfie toujours de ses programmes à
100 mesures censées rien parce que si on
en prend tant que ça c'est qu'on n'a
aucune priorité est la dernière et pour
moi extrêmement importante et pour la
formule et nous avons retenu l'esprit du
small business act
mais pour l'agriculture je veux dire
qu'il faut maintenant changer le code
des marchés publics en inscrivant une
clause acteurs de proximité
le critère du prix ne peut plus être le
facteur unique d'attribution des marchés
publics français
parce que ferrer c'est toujours la même
chose
les plus gros font baisser les prix
massivement pour tuer tous les autres et
quand il se retrouve tout seul comme
c'est curieux
on voit que les prix repartent à la
hausse nous voulons au républicain que
les marchés publics les élus vous
puissiez choisir dans vos marchés
publics non pas simplement le
mieux-disant tarifaires mais celui qui
est le producteur de proximité qui
gardera de l'emploi qui permettra à
faire vivre un terroir et qui permettra
de faire découvrir notamment aux enfants
des écoles
les productions régionales
départementales
au local c'est pour moi un enjeu
extrêmement important aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas un maire il n'y a pas un président
de département il n'y a pas un président
de région qui prendrait ce risque parce
que s'il prend pas sur les doigts
le moins disant ils se retrouvent devant
un tribunal correctionnel
étant accusée des pires turpitudes
pourquoi parce qu'il a voulu choisir le
fromage qu'on joue qu'on fabrique dans
son département
ou parce qu'il a voulu privilégier les
éleveurs de sa région un mot maintenant
sur la ruralité la ruralité ne peut pas
être réduite à l'agriculture même si
l'agriculture c'est fondamental je veux
dire d'ailleurs que tous ceux qui me
parle du tourisme vert ont raison mais
j'oublie une chose il n'y a pas
d'exemple de touristes qui se développe
dans un territoire qui a perdu toute
activité de production
c'est un mensonge que de dire qu'on peut
avoir des activités de substitution avec
l'activité de production
regardez ce qu'on remarquablement fait
les élus de montagne jean patrick avec
l'or blanc ce qu'on appelle leur blanc
le développement des stations de sports
d'hiver
c'était un choix majeur du lendemain de
la guerre est prometteur est-ce que ça
l'a empêché de développer en même temps
leur appellation leurs produits
agricoles ce qui est vrai pour le
tourisme blanc est également vrai pour
le tourisme vert
c'est pour ça qu'il faut garder une
agriculture mais le temps est venu de
donner à la ruralité une priorité
lorsque nous sommes arrivés au
gouvernement avec jacques chirac en 2002
la priorité a été la banlieue les
périphéries de nos villes où il y avait
une situation catastrophe
jacques chirac comme moi par
l'intermédiaire de jean louis borloo et
de mon ami daubresse nous avons mis en
oeuvre un plan pour la ville de 40
milliards d'euros est aujourd'hui mes
chers amis quand vous circulez à la
périphérie de nos villes vous ne voyez
plus ces grands ensembles délabré qui
défiguraient nos villes nous avons fait
ce travail
aujourd'hui la priorité c'est la
ruralité qui s'est senti abandonné qui
s'est senti humilié et qui s'est dit
c'est pas parce que nous on casse pas
les abribus qu'on souffre moins c'est
pas parce que nous on est moins nombreux
que les moins importants et donc le
temps est venu d'un véritable plan
marshall pour la ruralité dans ce plan
nous affichons un premier principe c'est
le principe de parité 1 euro investi
dans la ville doit correspondre à un
euro investi dans nos campagnes
la parité parce que nos campagnes ne
veulent pas mourir et nous ne voulons
pas qu'elle meure la france c'est pas
simplement dit ville 20 ville tranquille
la france c'est le pays d'europe à la
superficie la plus large
la priorité c'est clairement ce plan
marshall pour la ruralité c'est un plan
que nous envisageons alentours de 10
milliards d'euros avait des contrats de
revers revitalisation qui seront
proposés qui permettront d'obtenir un
fort effet de levier financier de l'état
plan de revitalisation qu'on calquera
sur la politique de rénovation urbaine
qu'on a défini cher marc philippe dans
la loi du 1er août 2003
il s'agit de concentrer les moyens
financiers de la puissance publique sur
des objectifs ciblés et prioritaire
pendant une durée limitée de 5 ans en
mutualisant les moyens de l'état de la
région et des départements
c'est con cra pourrait couvrir
l'ensemble des grands enjeux de la
ruralité
je pense à la santé je pense à
l'enseignement aux services publics au
développement numérique au logement au
maintien des commerces ainsi que des
entreprises
je souhaite d'ailleurs que dans cette
vision on ne voit pas le monde rural
comme un mondant disparition mais comme
on le voit comme un monde qui peut
devenir compétitif au même titre que la
ville je refuse que les zones rurales
n'accède pas à des infrastructures
modernes et de qualité
il s'agit pas de maintenir sous
perfusion des zones à qui nous diront
encore une minute monsieur le bourreau
vous avez encore quelques années à vivre
mais de créer les conditions d'un
développement économique harmonieux de
ces zones on va quand même pas vivre
dans plus beau pays du monde
en concentrant tout le monde dans des
villes qui vont devenir invivable
parce que des gens sont obligés de
quitter la ruralité
n'ayant plus d'emploi n'ayant plus de
services ayant plus de possibilités pour
venir grossir des villes on peut plus
circuler
on peut plus respirer et on n'a plus de
logement
c'est un calcul fou c'est un calcul qui
n'a pas de sens il faut donc investir
dans ces contrats de revitalisation je
voudrais d'ailleurs dire que j'avais
créé six cent quarante deux pôles
d'excellence souvenez vous à l'époque
car le pôle d'excellence pour moi
c'était pas simplement crawl avec 3
milliards d'investissements près de
grenoble
un pôle d'excellence ça peut avoir cent
cinquante mille euros d'investissement
l'excellence ne se comptent pas
simplement milliards on peut être
excellent en choisissant sa niche son
secteur pour donner à chaque territoire
mais quoi la possibilité de se
développer de proposer des emplois et
d'imaginer
son avenir ses rôles ces zones de
revitalisation rurale avec exonérations
fiscales exonérations de charges
sociales nous avions consacré un demi
milliard pour la ruralité
nous devrons reprendre cette politique
que chacun en france que chaque
territoire se sentent armes égales pour
vivre et préparer son avenir
ce qui veut dire que nous devrons
prendre des responsabilités lourdes
notamment sur la question de l'accès aux
soins et à la santé dans la ruralité
la première préoccupation c'est la santé
on n'a plus de docteur
on a plus de formation on a plus
d'infirmières je rappelle que nous
avions développé les maisons
pluridisciplinaires de santé
j'en avais créé 230 450 était en projet
je voudrais dire ma disponibilité à
envisager que le même acte médical soit
mieux rémunéré dans une zone de
désertification médicale que dans une
zone de trop grandes
démographie médicale parce que dans une
zone de désertification médicale être un
médecin
c'est du service public c'est une
mission de service public et cette
mission de service public
il est normal qu'elles soient rémunérés
de la même façon je souhaite qu'on
développe à grande échelle les bourses
pour les étudiants en médecine
je ne verrais que des avantages à ce que
l'état paye la formation des étudiants
en médecine pour que ceux ci puissent
exercer pendant cinq ou six ans dans une
région en sous démographie médicale
à la condition à la condition que quand
on fait ses études à montpellier ne soit
plutôt envoyé en lozère dans le pas de
calais et quand on fait ses études de
médecine à lille conçoit plutôt
qu'envoyer dans le pas-de-calais cher
daniel que à toulon voilà parce que avec
la logique administrative française
qu'en général on dit un étudiant du nord
de la france vous serez bien d'aller
dans le sud et en étudiant du sud allez
vous voilà avec 1000 km de sa famille
non je pense qu'il est urgent de régler
cette question là enfin je voudrais
annoncer pour la ruralité un moratoire
sur toutes les normes qui concerne la
ruralité pour les cinq ans qui viennent
et par ailleurs la souplesse pour les
normes les maires de nos petites
communes n'en peuvent plus écoutez dans
les programmes de logements sociaux
il est quand même curieux de voir la
taille des salles de bains la taille des
chambres pour enfants ya une raison à
cela c'est que désormais toutes les
salles de bains doivent être accessibles
pour un fauteuil handicapé ce qui fait
qu'on a des salles de bains immense avec
des chambres pour enfants tout petit et
ce qui ne serait pas mieux au lieu de
mettre toutes les salles de bain d'un
ensemble hlm possiblement avec le
fauteuil handicapé de réserver 10% des
appartements réellement aux handicapés
est réellement équipé pour les
handicapés plutôt que de mettre aux
normes tous les appartements d'une
résidence hlm
à l'école est ce qu'il ne serait pas
utile dans un village dans une commune
d'avoir une ou deux écoles pour
accueillir des enfants handicapés
plutôt que d'obliger toutes les écoles
avoir un système d'ascenseur
ce qui rend les coups en situation
d'explosion et que dire de ces parkings
hlm vide parce qu'on oblige à construire
des parkings pour des populations qui
n'ont pas de voiture
ce qui n'est pas quand même une parfaite
adéquation des moyens et des
possibilités de chacun
enfin je terminais en disant un mot de
la nouvelle carte cantonale décidé par
l'actuel gouvernement
je dis tout de suite que nous nous
sentons pas engagé par le scandaleux
découpage départemental et cantonales
qui a été réalisé nous reviendrons sur
ce découpage qui a été fait dans des
conditions invraisemblables quant aux
grandes régions nous interrogerons
chaque région pour savoir celles qui
veulent continuer ou celles qui veulent
retrouver leur liberté leur autonomie
par rapport à la situation d'avant mois
encore sur la gendarmerie gelé indiqué
compte tenu de la gravité de la
situation sécuritaire en france les
effectifs opérationnels de la
gendarmerie seront sanctuarisés
et je voudrais qu'on réfléchisse à la
possibilité pour les jeunes de faire une
année de service national dans la
gendarmerie au service de la sécurité
dans la ruralité
je trouve que on aurait là une
opportunité formidable pour les jeunes
ça renforcerait les effectifs de la
gendarmerie dans la ruralité la
gendarmerie c'est l'armée donc ça serait
un service militaire dans la gendarmerie
on renforcerait la sécurité ruralité on
donnera une possibilité à des jeunes de
passer un an
à se former dans une brigade de
gendarmerie naturellement cela
concernerait les femmes comme les hommes
et on ne pourra pas me dire que c'est
trop cher parce que c'est l'ensemble
d'une classe d'âge c'est à dire sept
cent mille jeunes se seraient ciblés sur
la gendarmerie je crois que cela fait
partie des idées que l'on doit retenir
en résumé mes chers amis vous l'avez
compris pour nous l'agriculture c'est
aussi important que les nanotechnologies
le spatial l'aéronautique l'agriculture
c'est un enjeu majeur quant à la
ruralité c'est pas le passé c'est notre
avenir
la ruralité c'est la capacité de la
france d'imaginer un avenir apaisé où
chacun pourra trouver son propre style
de vie où personne ne sera condamné à
l'exil
quand on voit les mouvements de
population qui se passe à l'échelle de
la planète
et bien moi je n'ai pas envie qu'en
france il ya des mouvements de
population équivalent non pas parce
qu'on a choisi d'aller ailleurs
mais parce qu'on ne peut plus vivre on
avait choisi de vivre
c'est ça l'enjeu et je vous remercie de
l'avoir compris d'être venus si nombreux
des questions vous seront posées ce
n'est qu'une étape de plus dans la
démarche des républicains pour préparer
le grand projet d'alternance la ruralité
et l'agriculture seront au coeur du
projet d'alternance pour 2017
je vous laisse